la ministre de la santé et des affaires
sociales est l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir marisol touraine ans et merci
d'être avec nous pour nous éclairer sur
un grand nombre de questions qui vous
incombe est qu'ils sont très variées
nous allons le voir
bruno franceschi de l' agence
france-presse notre partenaire nous
rejoindra dans un instant nouvelles
réformes pour sauver les retraites et
puis tour de vis budgétaire de quelque
60 milliards d'euros 1 durant le
quinquennat pour s'attaquer donc au
déficit public et la politique familiale
sera forcément touché on imagine déjà
que la gauche du ps va à nouveau se
faire entendre peut-être même hurlé vous
serez interrogé sur ces questions dans
la deuxième partie de l'émission
enfin mickaël szames s de public sénat
nous rejoindra après un portrait de vous
pour mieux vous connaître d'abord bien
sûr le rapport 6/4 sur la fin de vie pas
question de s'orienter à priori vers
l'euthanasie active mais une porte est
entrouverte sur le suicide assisté est
ce qu'une brèche est ouverte avec ses
propositions du rapport qui vont avec
manifestement reprises dans la
proposition de loi dont dans le prend
dans le projet de loi dont vous aurez la
charge
le président de la république s'était
engagé pendant la campagne il s'était
engagé à ce qu' une aide active puisse
être apportée à ceux qui confrontés à
une maladie grave et incurable et ne
vivent pas leur fin de vie de manière
digne puisse être aidé il a donc
souhaité qu'un débat s'engage et c'est
ce débat qu'a menées le professeur
sicard avec son groupe qui a permis la
présentation du rapport remis ce matin
au président de la république
ce rapport montre qu'il ya de très
grandes attentes et nous savons bien les
français aujourd'hui souhaitent que leur
liberté leur dignité leurs droits soient
reconnus jusqu'au bout de leur vie ils
veulent vivre pleinement y compris dans
la maladie
et décider de la façon dont leur vie
doit doit s'arrêter et donc face à cela
le rapport fait un certain nombre de
préconisations d'orientation mais très
générale et c'est pourquoi le président
de la république a souhaité saisir le
comité consultatif national d'éthique
pour que des précisions soient apportées
sur qui on suivre précise danse est un
débat qui ne sera plus public c'est le
comité qui va se réunir et remettre
avant le mois d'avril prochain
des recommandations sur la manière
précise dont on peut améliorer les soins
palliatifs qui aujourd'hui sont mal
connus et compris du personnel soignant
sur la manière dont très strictement
encadré on pourrait imaginer que une
personne fasse le geste elle même de
mettre fin c'est là le malade lui-même
et puis sur le suicide assisté c'était
donc c'est une des nouveautés peut-être
qui apparaît dans ce rapport on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a là une demande est
aussi une façon de respecter la volonté
des médecins de rester en dehors de ce
processus
et puis une réflexion sur la dignité ce
qu'est ce que c'est que accompagner le
malade dans la dignité jusqu'au bout de
sa vie il y aura une réflexion qui va
aboutir au mois d'avril
et c'est sur cette base là que un projet
de loi sera présenté alors ça veut dire
que l'euthanasie active le geste médical
pour mettre fin à la vie n'est pas
exclue dans ce projet de loi vous vous
dites il faut accompagner
il faut que le personnel médical
accompagne également je ne dis pas il
faut je dis simplement que le président
la république a souhaité que le comité
national consultatif d'éthique puissent
définir les conditions dans lesquelles
se serait tu envisageable à partir des
recommandations que fera le comité
consultatif
nous élaborons un projet de loi met donc
on voit bien qu'il ya trois orientations
précises qui sont données est fixé à la
réflexion moi je veux souligner que ça
représente un pas très important brèche
poser la question en tout cas pas un pas
en avant
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire je crois
que il est temps de pouvoir mieux
prendre en compte les attentes de nos
concitoyens leur volonté de dignité et
que cette dignité s'exprime et soient
réalisés jusqu'au bout de la sps que le
mot était nazi sera dans le texte de loi
parce que on a manifestement je vais
formuler consultatif des fuites d'eau de
quoi est ce qu'on parle on parle de dé
manière de permettre à une personne qui
est malade qui est confronté à une
maladie incurable qui portent atteinte à
la conception qu'elle a d'elle-même
relation qu'elle peut avoir avec ses
proches ou avec son entourage qui l'a
fait souffrir de façon forte donc on
parle de ces personnes là et on se
demande comment on peut répondre à leurs
demandes
lorsque leur demande c'est évidemment
comment on peut répondre à leur demande
de finir leur vie dans la dignité et
bien un cadre précis qui répondent à des
règles éthiques forte un cadre précis et
stricte évidemment être élaborée et
c'est ce à quoi nous allons travailler
puisque le rapport sicard a été remis à
partir du moment où le comité
consultatif d'éthique aura rendu ses
conclusions voilà on avance avec
prudence elle beaucoup de précautions
sur ce sujet délicat ce sujet délicat
pour le coup il n'y a pas d'urgence
il y a une volonté qui ait marqué un
engagement a été pris par le président
de la république pendant la campagne une
volonté et marquer mais aussi une
volonté que ces avancées se réalise de
façon évidemment très encadré et crème
excusez moi je retiens à vous utiliser
le mot brèche vous l'acceptez lorsqu'il
se fait jusqu'à présent
est-ce que néanmoins le corps médical
les médecins les infirmières pourraient
être associés demain un geste qui me met
fin à la vie ou est-ce que ça doit
demeurer pour vous un tabou c'est une
des savoirs et c'est ce que ça restera
un tabouret ou non réfection
gouvernementale s'engagera une fois que
le rapport du comité consultatif aura
été remués nous avons besoin d'être
éclairés très concrètement sur la façon
dont les choses se passent moi j'entends
les réticences les réserves les doutes
qui s'exprime dans le corps médical par
summer est accablant pour vous je crois
que nous ne vont pas aujourd'hui avoir
de tabou si ce n'est évidemment celui la
volonté de la personne nous devons
évidemment faire en sorte que soient
garantis le fait que la personne prend
la décision est accompagné dans sa
décision
et c'est un des sujets sur lesquels nous
devons travailler davantage
rendez vous donc dans quelques mois avec
ce texte très important évidemment
autres sujets de société le mariage gay
ou entre personnes de même sexe puisque
le gouvernement n'a pas d'avis marisol
touraine et se remet au parlement est ce
que vous vous êtes vous personnellement
favorable à la à l'aide médicale à la
procréation pour les couples de
lesbiennes la procréation médicalement
assistée représente une possibilité pour
les couples de lesbiennes d'avoir un
enfant à l'étranger le pratiquer à
l'étranger où cette réflexion là elle
est dans le débat et la question c'est
est ce qu'elle sera
est ce qu'elle sera dans le texte de
guillaume intentions examen elle ne sera
pas d'entracte moment le gouvernement ne
change pas de position il va présenter
un texte qui porte sur le mariage
il devrait bien reprendre position qu on
est député
le débat il ya besoin de résoudre un
certain nombre de questions autour de la
procréation médicalement assistée
est ce que ces questions pourront être
réglés dans le cadre du débat
parlementaire et donc aboutir dès ce
débat là c'est la réflexion des
parlementaires qui va permettre de le
dire mais la procréation médicalement
assistée
elle est dans le débat et si les
parlementaires souhaitent que elles
aboutissent dès le mois de janvier à
l'occasion de la discussion sur le
mariage pour tous eh bien ces
dispositions abouti c'est aussi de
réflexion qui a lieu au sein
goût bien sûr pas ce choix là cette
option là le gouvernement assume dans la
mesure où il dit aux parlementaires que
leur réflexion sera évidemment suivi
avec beaucoup d'attention et je crois
que franchement c'est une discussion qui
ne porte pas sur l'objectif faudra-t-il
permettre la procréation médicalement
assistée aux couples de femmes ou pas la
question c'est est-ce qu on le fait
maintenant où est-ce qu'on le fait un
peu plus tard dans le cadre d'un autre
le débat c'est uniquement celui là sur
le principe il me semble que nous allons
vers l'adoption de la possibilité de la
procréation médicalement assistée
très bien mais en deux temps donc à
paris soit la question est de savoir
c'est que parlementaire pense qu'on peut
le faire dès ce texte là où qu'on doit
les deux premiers textes et bien le
gouvernement sera évidemment très
attentifs à l'ordre alors une question
concernant la pilule de troisième
génération dont les dangers sont
maintenant connues on a tous était
d'ailleurs ému par le témoignage de
cette jeune femme qui a été victime d'un
accident vasculaire en avait c'est parce
qu'elle prenait cette pilule pourquoi
vous n'interdisez pas tout simplement
parce que ça n'est pas de mon ressort
le celle agence nationale de la sécurité
du médicament qui prend la décision de
mettre sur le marché ou d'interdire de
retirer du marché un médicament et la
pilule est un médicament en revanche
j'ai saisi la haute autorité de santé je
lui ai demandé quelle est l analyse qu
elles faisaient des risques de cette
pilule et au regard des analyses qu'elle
m'a transmis j'ai indiqué que cette
pilule serait déremboursés et j'ai
demandé que soit informée de façon
extrêmement rapide et vigoureuse
l'ensemble des médecins des risques et
des bonnes pratiques concrètement ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de raison de
proposer spontanément à une femme de
prendre la pilule de 3e génération on
apporte rien elles n'apportent rien de
pour la très grande majorité des cas il
ya des femmes pour qui ça représente une
possibilité pour raisons médicales
il ne faut pas le nier mais cette pilule
a bénéficié passez moi l'expression d'un
effet de
il ya 5 millions de femmes qui prennent
pilule de troisième ou quatrième
génération et c'est devenu en quelque
sorte la pilule dont parlent les jeunes
femmes en particulier et des médecins il
faut en finir avec ce réflexe qui
consiste à la prescrire dans l'est et
spontanément une question sur les
médicaments génériques est ce que vous
allez à poser alors c'est parce que
c'est votre ressort là que la
composition et surtout la provenance
géographique des molécules apparaissent
sur les paquets comme le demandait qu'à
dresser on s'aperçoit effectivement on
veut bien être confiant dans les
médicaments génériques mois s'aperçoit
que 80% des molécules viennent de chine
ou d'inde où les contrôles sont
défaillants les molécules de tous les
médicaments qu'il s'agisse des
médicaments de marque ou des médicaments
génériques sont très massivement
fabriqués en dehors de l'union
européenne dont il n'y a pas de
différence je veux insister là dessus il
n'y a pas de différence dans la
composition et la fabrication des
médicaments génériques et des
médicaments de maintenance et pour l'eau
lancé pour l'ensemble des médicaments
que nous devons évidemment mettre en
place une politique plus insistantes de
contrôle de contrôle sur place et je
souhaite aussi pouvoir convaincre mes
partenaires européens de s'engager dans
cette même démarche parce que si nous la
menons ensemble nous aurons davantage de
moyens
et après tout nous pouvons faire
confiance à l'allemagne à la belgique ou
à l'angleterre si elle va faire des
contrôles dans des pays extérieurs ça
pourrait par le référencement il n'y a
pas de vengeance là-dessus nous avons
besoin de plus de transparence
nous avons besoin de contrôles renforcés
mais cela c'est pour l'ensemble des
médicaments un mot sur gérard depardieu
il a dit qu'il a donc rendu son
passeport mais également sa carte vitale
dont il n'a jamais fait usage vous allez
vérifier ce point là non je n'ai pas
vérifié je crois que aujourd'hui au fou
il faut tourner la page de cet épisode
un peu regrettable et malheureuse
peut-être pour lui et au fonds appelé à
la solidarité dans nos pays nous vivons
une période de crise et il est utile que
chacune chacun fasse preuve d'esprit de
solidarité pour le redressement de la
france parce que c'est bien de ça qu'il
s'agit
il faut que notre pays aille de l'avant
et c'est en se serrant les coudes
le ministre belge des affaires
étrangères qui est dit bon moi je suis
prêt à accueillir tous les français qui
viennent d'ailleurs ya 500 demandes de
naturalisation
vous parlez vous parlez des contrôlés au
niveau de l'europe là au niveau de
l'europe fiscale ce sont les avancées
que nous avons à faire encore aller oui
on a beaucoup parlé de sujets de société
ça m'a même à gauche estiment qu'ils
servent aujourd'hui au gouvernement de
diversion des chemins de traverse dit
par exemple jean pierre chevènement pas
vous pas vous on a compris marisol
touraine vous estimez bien que ces
réformes vont de pair avec les réformes
sociales qui s'annonce d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus dur très dur on va le voir
dans un instant on va parler des
retraites et puis des économies sur ce
thème avant d'accueillir notre confrère
bale afp bruno franceschi
l'enquète de jérôme ravier mariage pour
tous fin de vie droit de vote des
étrangers ou encore celle de shoot le
gouvernement repart à l'offensive sur
les questions sociétales sur le mariage
pour tous la gauche ne pouvait laisser
la rue à l'opposition il s'agit aussi de
faire oublier les cafouillages autour de
florange
le plus important c'est déjà d'arriver
de la part de la gauche a montré qu'il
ya des mesures de gauche qui sont
entreprises il pourrait s'agit en tout
cas c'est le cas pas l'art actuel de la
première et véritable confrontation
entre la gauche et la droite qui est pas
mais en tout cas momentanément de au
peuple de gauche et se retrouver dans le
gouvernement il ya le président annick
au sein du parti plusieurs visions
s'opposent
cette semaine quinze parlementaires
demandent de privilégier des mesures sur
le pouvoir d'achat mais pour la
direction
toutes ces réformes sont conciliables
mêmes complémentaires la mobilisation
très forte des socialistes pour porter
encore une fois ce droit nouveau dans la
grande tradition d'une gauche qui marche
sur ses deux pieds
le social et le sociétal je pense que
dans l' équilibre
personne ne peut dire aujourd'hui que
l'offensé du parti socialiste s'engage
en particulier ou principalement sur le
terrain sociétal aux marches sur
nos deux pieds l'offensif socialiste
sert aussi à souder toutes les
composantes de la gauche divisée sur les
questions de budget notamment
mais les partenaires ne sont pas dupes
moi je me refuse à opposer des questions
qui se fait sociétal à 2 qu'il ne le
serait pas pour moi une politique de
gauche elle doit vraiment être sur tous
les fronts
oui au mariage pour tous bien évidemment
oui au droit de vote des résidents
étrangers
mais oui aussi à des mesures qui
répondent aux besoins des gens l'ailé
gauche du parti socialiste mettait aussi
en garde d'autres gouvernements
socialistes européens ont chuté les
avancées sociétales n'ayant pas suffi à
faire oublier une politique de rigueur
du gouvernement zapatero qui a cru qu on
allait satisfaire les classes moyennes
avec des mesures phare sur le champ
sociétal qui est utile mais force est de
constater ça ne suffit pas s'il n'y a
pas au rendez-vous et des réponses
sociales françois hollande et le
gouvernement sont prévenus s'ils veulent
capitaliser sur les réformes de société
toutes les composantes de la gauche
n'avaleront pas pour autant les
tournants dans le domaine économique
voilà bruno franceschi est avec nous de
l'agencé france-presse bon enfin renault
souvent question il ya un autre gros
dossier qui va arriver très
prochainement sa réforme des retraites
le conseil d'orientation des retraites
vient de rendre son rapport enfin pas eu
de frappes publiquement demain mercredi
on en connaît déjà l'essentiel on
s'aperçoit qu'à la forme du 2006 n'est
pas du tout abouti bien au contraire les
déficits se creusent
la gauche n'a jamais réformé les
retraites est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est vraiment le moment de la grande
réforme des retraites tant attendu je
vais vous répondre bien sûr mais si vous
permettez je voudrais réagir au
reportage que vous avez présenté parce
que je crois qu'on a tort d'opposer les
réformes sociales aux réformes
sociétales
s'il s'agit de dire que les évolutions
que nous proposons pour le mariage pour
tous sur la fin de vie par exemple ne
permettent pas de répondre aux attentes
en matière d'emploi c'est une évidence
c'est évidemment une priorité pour nous
que de faire en sorte que notre pays se
redresse créer des emplois à créer de la
richesse pour avoir des politiques
sociales fortes mais
ne me retrouve pas dans cette opposition
comme si on était sommée de choisir la
gauche c'est le progrès c'est
l'évolution de la société dans
l'ensemble la société voulait la changez
vous le dites dans la ville semaine
dernière vous voulez changer la société
la société change je ne crois pas que le
politique change la société mais le
politique les responsables politiques
doivent prendre en considération les
évolutions de la société et parfois
d'ailleurs les anticiper souvenez vous
la peine de mort en 1981 si on avait
fait un référendum sur la question il
n'est pas certain que françois
mitterrand l'aurait gagné il est même à
peu près certain qu'il leur ait perdu ce
qui ne l'a pas empêché de sang alors sur
les retraites
le rapport que vous évoquez qui sera
présenté effectivement demain au conseil
d'orientation des retraites apporte des
éléments assez intéressant d'abord ils
soulignent comme vous le faite que la
réforme du précédent gouvernement n'a
pas permis de régler la situation à
court terme puisque cette réforme était
prévu pour aboutir à l'équilibré en 2018
et que si nous ne faisons rien en 2018
l'équilibré ne sera pas du tout au
rendez vous nous avons il montera autour
de 20 milliards d'euros ça dépend des
des hypothèses qui sont retenus la
télécommande wii c'est pas tellement la
crise est probablement que la réforme
elle même n'était pas organisée d'une
manière qui permettait de répondre au
défi des retraites nous l'avions
d'ailleurs souligner est de retour
depuis il s'agissait d'avoir une réforme
plus plus cohérente
il ya eu un refus absolu notamment en
matière de prélèvements à ce moment là
c'est ce qui met ça pour régler les
problèmes
vous savez soit vous posez sur les
cotisations soit ainsi posée sur scène
nouvelle cotisation soit vous peser sur
le niveau des retraites donc il y a
plusieurs options
en revanche ce que dit le rapport et qui
est très intéressant c'est que en raison
notamment de la vitalité démographique
de la france
le défi à relever dans le long terme et
60 où l on met même à partir les on
commence à partir de 2035
d'après le rapport à voir s'infléchir
les com et donc les enjeux ne sont pas
aussi pesant en terme financier cela
veut dire que une réflexion doit
s'engager cela a été annoncé à l'issue
de la concertation de la grande
conférence sociale du mois de juillet le
corps doit encore si j'ose dire nous
présenter un rapport
un autre rapport sur plus générale sur
le système des retraites au mois de
janvier et à partir de là nous allons
engager une concernant vous écouter vous
regardez les choses à très long terme
pour peut-être nous signifier que la
gauche ne va pas tranchée mais je vous
ai dit il y a un enjeu à court terme est
soulignée par le rapport il y à des
enjeux à long terme parce que vous avez
on ne peut pas uniquement piloter le
système des retraites en étant le nez
sur le guidon de donner de la visibilité
de la visibilité ça veut pas dire que
l'on réfléchisse forcément à 2060
ça veut dire que quelqu'un qui
aujourd'hui à 45 45 ans doit pouvoir
savoir selon quels principes il pourra
partir en réflexion doit être doit être
large et mais la réflexion d'être marche
même moment un autre mais décidé de nous
engager une concertation
vous êtes prêt à défier b ya certaines
urgences pardon pardon michel y être il
ya certaines urgences quand même on voit
bien que dans le fond aussi pour le
monde fait rien vous l'avez souligné les
déficits augmentent
on voit bien que dans sont les solutions
qui peuvent être proposées c'est soi
le recul de l'âge de la retraite il
propose même si moi quelque chose qui a
été qu était la dernière fois en 2010
singulièrement contestée par des mesures
courageuses effective ça n'est pas les
mesures courageuses sûrement il faut
qu'on s'entende sur les mesures
courageuses mais encore une fois moi je
ne vais pas tranchée avant que la
concertation soit engagé c'est quand
même une priorité que de pouvoir
échanger et mettre à plat les
différentes options
mais le rapport est plus subtile sur la
sur les six mois que vous évoquez il ne
préconise pas de reporter de six mois
l'âge légal de départ en retraite il dit
que ce qui compte c'est d'ailleurs la
vérité ce qui compte c'est moins l'âge
légal que l'âge auquel très concrètement
vous partez en retraite et c'est ça qui
est en jeu et il faut que des gens qui
ont travaillé dans des conditions
satisfaisantes puisse partir un peu plus
tard c'est ce qui est indiqué en
particulier je me suis ce rapport la
discussion aura lieu
honnêtement nous n'en sommes qu'au début
puisque le rapport arrive demain et pas
nous a dit qu'un curseur je suis un de
françois hollande durant la campagne qui
évoquait souvent l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation c'est un élément
tout à fait important parce que certains
égards écoutez tout est sur la corde
tout sera sur la table
encore une fois la concertation va
s'engager il y a des objectifs à comment
dire à atteindre mais nous devons nous
donner le temps de la réflexion et de la
concertation mais pas l'impression
d'être au pied du mur le pied le mur
nous allons à l'escaladé avec les
partenaires sociaux le gouvernement ne
pourra pas l'escaladé sun oui bon ok ça
moi je veux dire la discussion là elle
rassemble des partenaires sociaux au
conseil d'orientation des retraites
nous verrons comment avancer encore une
fois je les dis la concertation s'engage
au début de l'année prochaine et il me
semble que ce rapport est celui de la
fin du mois de janvier sont tout à fait
utile pour que chacun mesure l'ampleur
des responsabilités on touche pas la
répartition
là dessus le principe est à tort gym
lors on ne va pas non plus vers la
capitalisation à la capitalisation
c'est pas possible pas danser non
seulement ça n'est pas notre souhait
mais ça n'est pas notre choix c'est à
dire que pour nous il éveille pour moi
pour le gouvernement il est absolument
clair que le système de retraite par
répartition qui est un système de
justice et de solidarité doit être
préservé c'est bien ça qu'il s'agit de
consolider c'est une réforme pas pour le
plaisir de réformer c'est une réforme
pour consolider un système de solidarité
dans un contexte j'insiste qui est un
con c'est un contexte économiquement
contrat mais qui est aussi dans un
contexte démographiquement favoris alors
pour la défense on nous parle souvent de
l'allemagne l'allemagne a dû faire des
choix qui était imposé par un protection
graphique très vite elle a repoussé
l'âge de départ est ce qu'on peut et
est-ce que c'est inconcevable en france
on a le doigt est ce que c'est
inconcevable en de repousser encore
l'âge de départ à la retraite
mais robben dire oui ou non à ce que je
vous dis simplement qu'on ne peut pas
faire comme si un pays comme l'allemagne
où le taux de fécondité est de 1,3 1,3
enfant par femme alors que en france
il approche les 2 enfants par femme on
est à 1 95 on ne peut pas considérer que
la question des retraites se présentent
dans les mêmes termes et en tout cas
pour nous d'où là elle sera abordée avec
l'esprit de justice parce que c'est ça
aussi dans notre prière éléments de
comparaison avec l'allemagne qui ne veut
au moins favorable alors votre question
il n'ya pas que ça il ya aussi des
déficits publics et qui
sont tellement à bissau que le
gouvernement si je comprends bien
elle a décidé de faire un certain nombre
d'économies 60 milliards d'ici la fin du
quinquennat c'est énorme
et donc ça va avoir un impact sur
énormément de dossiers et
particulièrement les vôtres et attend
sur la petite familiale est ce que on
peut s'attendre à une diminution des
prestations familiales est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre effectivement à une
revisitation si j'ose le terme de
mécanismes de fonctionnement de ces ses
prestations par exemple qui tienne
compte du revenu des ménages
le premier ministre a présidé ce matin
comité interministériel avec l'ensemble
des ministres pour engager une politique
de simplification administrative ce qui
est générateur d'économies et une
politique d'évaluation de
nos actions en matière sociale mais en
matière de logement en matière
économique en matière d'enseignement
supérieur de recherche enfin dans tous
les domaines il s'agit d'évaluer et de
se demander si attendait que vous parlez
de politique familiale et politique
familiale aujourd'hui ne sont pas
davantage concerné que les autres
politiques du gouvernement il s'agit de
se demander ce que sont les objectifs à
atteindre et si les politiques qui
aujourd'hui fonctionne sont les mieux
calibrée pour permettre d'atteindre ces
objectifs les politiques sociales elles
ont évidemment des objectifs de justice
d'accompagnement de soutien
est ce que ces objectifs là sont bien
remplies nous allons procéder à ce
travail est avancé ce n'est à l'évidence
nous avons des économies à faire moi je
le dis après tkm égal au risque de
l'impopularité sociales doivent être
évalués il n'y a pas de raison que parce
qu'elles sont sociales ces politiques là
reste intangible je ne crois pas que
nous n'avons par exemple sur les
allocations familiales on pourrait
s'interroger effectivement sur les
ménages les plus aisés qui en seraient
privés de moins de tabous on va évaluer
les politiques on va évaluer les
politiques voir comment elle fonctionne
pour aboutir à des décisions qui doivent
à la fois mieux servir nos concitoyens
mieux accompagner nos concitoyens et
puis permettre de faire des économies on
ne peut pas imaginer que ce soit des
politiques une quand viendra le temps de
la décision parce que sur la retraite
sur les vraies économies en mode et on
évalue on n'évalue pas écouté on évalue
à un comité ce comité se réunit tous les
trois mois se réunira tous les trois
mois il a été entendu que les économies
devaient être faites sur plusieurs
années je crois qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'annoncé en quelques jours des
décisions qui sont évidemment tout à
fait importante mais pour l'impopulaire
rapport
les évaluations elles sont déjà connus
ils sont déjà fait après c'est une
question de choix et on a le sentiment
que dans le fond pour le moment comme
dit michel on est vraiment dans la
réflexion et touil et qu'on hésite un
peu raide a décidé comme s'il y avait un
enjeu de popularité derrière de
présidence au nom non vous parler du
rapport la cour des comptes
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour la cour
des comptes et le mangera de la cour
daté de notre les niches sociales
oui mais non je l'aï les pas de mettre
mieux en oeuvre des politiques sur le
plan technique il s'agit de s'interroger
sur des objectifs politiques à atteindre
et ça c'est pas la cour des comptes qui
doit le faire à la place du gouvernement
donc nous devons nous dire en matière
d'assurance maladie en matière de
famille en matière de handicap pour les
sujets mme qui me concerne on pourrait
parler de l'enseignement de la recherche
de l'agriculture c'est une décision
qu'on voie des signes assez bien la
question les choses alors deux nageurs
question juste viennent dans les mois
qui viennent je voulais aussi vous dire
que la question de la popularité est une
question qui évidemment préoccupe
franchement et vaut mieux être populaire
qu impopulaire c'est une évidence dont
vous m'accorderez aisément que elle
s'impose
mais françois hollande l'a dit le
président de la république l'a répété
encore hier lorsqu'il était en
déplacement chaponost ans à
château-renault dans l'indre et loire
dans mon département
il a il a indiqué que sa seule volonté
sa seule préoccupation c'était de
prendre les mesures qui s'imposaient
pour le redressement de notre pays et
pour l'amélioration de la sécrétion
braver l'impopularité populaire ça
l'enjeu c'est ça l'enjeu c'est de se
dire j'ai un cap
je fixe un cap le gouvernement s'inscrit
dans cette orientation et nous avons
comme priorité l'emploi l'activité
économique l'emploi le redressement du
pays derrière question bruno est-ce que
vous avez l'impression d'être devenu un
peu populaire auprès des médecins
d'accord justement ces dépassements
d'honoraires sur les décisions que vous
avez prises sur les déserts médicaux jeu
reprend une phrase de nora berra que je
trouvais un peu amusantes
elle considère que vous avez ripoliné
des mesures existant c'était une
expression à maison mais à la hauteur de
l'absence totale de politique et de
décision en la matière de la part du
gouvernement précédent auquel elle
participait j'aurais préféré ne pas
avoir à me retrouver dans une situation
où deux millions de français en cinq ans
se retrouve dans une zone de mesure que
nous avons pris des mesures nouvelles et
je n'ai dis-je mobilise l'ensemble des
acteurs l'ensemble des professionnels de
l'administration pour faire en sorte que
les français est accès à des soins de
proximité et cela est tout à fait
populaire auprès des médecins en
particulier des médecins généralistes
qui savent l'importance qu'il ya à
garantir de bonnes conditions de santé à
tous nos conseils qu'ils veulent surtout
être remplacés à leur cabinet parce
qu'ils ont du mal quand ils partent à la
retraite on le sait a notamment dans les
campings et dans certains quartiers il
faudra revoir l'organisation vous savez
là système de sang bleu viapresse qui
est l'enjeu
nous devons mettre en place des équipes
de professionnels dans les territoires
les plus en être à l'idée qu'il doit y
avoir un médecin isolé dans ses robinets
dans chaque village - des pôles de santé
auquel travaille comme aussi les élus
merci beaucoup bruno donc mickaël szames
mais je vais arriver depuis x ena juste
après cette enquête
bien sûr vous marisol touraine et donc
être signées alexandra et colinot avec
une personnalité vous allez voir
mais pas la découvrir et qui vous est
très proche on dit de marisol touraine
qu'elle a des convictions fortes
que ces dossiers sont connus sur le bout
des doigts fruit d'un travail sans
relâche mais elle ne pose jamais un mot
plus haut que l'autre
jamais de fantaisie non plus la fille du
sociologue alain touraine semble
toujours dans la mesure des gens lui
disent qu'elle est glacial elle n'est
pas glacial elle n'est pas froide
allaient certainement contrôler la seule
la seule image
elle qui m'a étonné c'est une photo que
j'ai ici chez moi et avec sa fille aînée
tout petit et c'est une photo
extrêmement maternelle elle se elle se
laisse complètement aller vient de
souplesse de relations de fusion
éternelle il y avait de beaux yeux la
logique aurait voulu qu'elle embrasse
une carrière universitaire comme son
père ou médicales comme son grand père
comme sa mère est comme son frère mais
son engagement politique n'a pas surpris
ses proches
ça a été un choix un moment donné puis
ensuite j'ai vraiment tenu je dirais
presque comme tout ce qu'elle fait c'est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de continuité
elle débute en politique aux côtés de
michel rocard un ami proche de son père
puis elle s'engage sur le terrain
pendant 15 ans comme député
d'indre-et-loire sa sensibilité deuxième
gauche héritage de son père là encore la
conduit auprès de dsk après l affaire du
sofitel la raison l'amène à soutenir
françois hollande
spécialiste des questions sociales au ps
le portefeuille qui lui revient en mai
dernier n'est pas une surprise là encore
c'est une histoire de continuité ils
sont devant une responsabilité énorme
c'est maintenant qu'on joue la vie ou la
mort de ce pays comme grand pays
alors je suis heureux lesquels
participent à une oeuvre qui est une
oeuvre de première importance il s'agit
pas de gérer la vie quotidienne il
s'agit d'empêcher que que l'auto termine
le contre un arbre difficile avec un tel
poids paternel sur les épaules de ne pas
viser l'excellence en permanence
voilà à l'excellence en permanence vous
avez encore un quart d'heure pour le
démontrer sur un plateau avec michaël
szames est ce qui nous a rejoint avec
elle bon soir
sourire aussi sur l'image du père à
chaque fois est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous assumez complètement ou
qui est difficile à porter j'assume
complètement c'est une fierté d'avoir un
père qui est un grand intellectuel en
même temps ça représente effectivement
une forme d'exigence très présente au
quotidien depuis depuis toujours mais
avec laquelle j'ai appris à vivre un
reportage et qu'il dit appliquer
studieuse et aujourd'hui quand on lit
quelques portraits en notant sérieuse
travailleuse
est ce que vous sentez peut-être plus
sérieuses que les hommes et les femmes
politiques qui vous entourent oh non je
ne crois pas je pense que tous mes
collègues sont un sérieux est pleinement
impliqué dans dans leur dossier mais en
tout cas pour ce qui me concerne je le
prends comme un compliment parce qu'il
vaut mieux connaître ses dossiers il
vaut mieux travailler quand on a des
responsabilités
on n'imaginerait pas qu'on dise un
ministre qu'il ne travaille pas donc je
le prends comme un compliment est ce qui
est des domaines où vous ne contrôlez
pas tout cette oreille
on va écouter ça je vais dire en tout
cas l'avis public n'est pas une vie où
on doit particulièrement se laisser
aller me semble-t-il joker dans sa
combine montrer enfin comme mon père
montre la photo où je suis avec ma fille
ma fille aînée bon c'est vrai mais
c'était comment dire dans la vie privée
en vacances je suis une mère je pense
avoir des rapports avec mes enfants qui
sont des rapports tout à fait évidemment
affectueux
et pas nécessairement contrôler mais je
veux dire la vie privée n'est pas la vie
publique moi je suis assez attaché à
cela vous avez quand même dans paris
match dans votre maison je me souviens
mais pas avec mes enfants
non non non autre donnée par univers on
peut lire il y en a eu de nombreux
depuis que vous êtes rentré au
gouvernement il ya quelque chose qui
vous agace c'est vrai quand on dit que
vous êtes glacial que vous pouvez
paraître un petit peu hautaine voire
cassante
est ce que ce sont des gens mal
intentionnés qui dit ça surement valais
la vie politique n'est n'est pas n'est
pas un comment dire un domaine où la
bienveillance ou là comment dire c'est
sûr il a justifié la jalousie au sirop
certes certainement au dif au niveau
lautier oui c'est sans doute vrai de
tous les milieux mais on dit volontiers
d'une femme qu'elle est au fond froide
lorsqu'elle maîtrise ses dossiers et si
elle ne les maîtrisent pas on va dire
qu'elle est ou insuffisamment on va dire
qu'elle est incompétente au fond on ne
sait pas très bien quel est le bon
équilibre pour les femmes donc je pense
qu'il ya aussi dans ses critiques à voir
avec ça mais en tout cas ceux qui
travaillent avec moi et ceux qui vivent
avec moi n'ont pas le sentiment d'être
face à un mur de glace
il ya un documentaire qui va sortir sur
france 3 centre qui va sortir au mois de
janvier ils vous ont suivi depuis votre
entrée au gouvernement et vous parlez du
pouvoir est ce qu'une femme politique
peu près temps de pouvoir également ah
oui pourquoi pas je trouve que le
pouvoir
c'est ce qui permet de transformer notre
environnement de portée des réformes de
faire des choses la question du pouvoir
c'est de savoir si on veut le pouvoir
pour lui-même ou si on veut le pouvoir
pour agir
est ce qui est intéressant c'est
évidemment le pouvoir pour agir et il me
semble que les femmes sont dans cette
démarche là il n'y a pas de raison que
les femmes récusé des pouvoirs et et
laisse la place aux hommes c'est au nom
de cette logique là parce qu'on a des
professions qui sont massivement
féminisé
avec des postes de responsabilité qui
sont massivement occupés par des hommes
est trop d'ambition peut-il nuire à une
femme politique puisqu'un homme trop
d'ambition nuit un homme comme à une
femme à une femme comme un homme si
l'ambition se portent pour elle même en
quelque sorte
l'ambition c'est celle d'une action au
service de son pays quand on est un
responsable politique jean bobby c'est
sur la question michel vous avez des
modèles en politique ou et au féminin je
voulais dire et me donne je sais pas si
j'ai des modèles il ya des hommes des
femmes avec qui j'ai travaillé des
personnes qui m'ont inspiré mais
j'essaye de tracer mon chemin non non je
veux dire j'ai commencé dans la vie
politique avec michel rocard qui m'a
beaucoup apporté par l'exigence qu'il
avait ou l'absence de wi l'exigence
qu'il avait dans le chemin qu'il qu'il
traçait sa conception très très très
morale de l'action politique par exemple
mais
vous avez parlé il est un instant de la
parité professionnelle qui fait défaut
en l'absence de mixité également de
certaines professions et un rapport de
l' ocde qui montre que si la parité
était respectée et bien ce serait un
gain pour la croissance absolument
phénoménale
ah oui parce que là ils ont ri chacun
une femme plutôt les hommes d'ailleurs
rééquilibrent leur vie personnelle et
leur vie professionnelle
oui on a on n'a pas gagné en réalité à
marginaliser les femmes ni
économiquement et ce rapport est très
intéressant ni évidemment socialement et
souvent des conquêtes qui sont présentés
comme des avancées dues à la
féminisation de la vie professionnelle
en réalité bénéficie à l'ensemble de la
société je pense par exemple à
l'exigence ou à la tente des femmes
d'une bonne conciliation entre la vie
professionnelle et la vie familiale
on voit qu'aujourd'hui cette demande qui
était présenté comme féminine est aussi
une demande portée par les hommes
tout est là avec michel mbono vous avez
parlé de la popularité de françois
hollande je vous ramener un petit peu
sur le terrain de la politique il ya eu
une tribune de députés socialistes qui
disent en fait à françois hollande il ne
respecte pas ses priorités il ne
resterait pas les ouvriers également à
ce qu'il mette trop de pression sur les
épaules de françois hollande ses députés
ils ont exprimé leur position de deux
députés le président de la république a
rappelé qu'il avait fixé le cap et que
ce cap il ne s'en détourner pas
l'objectif c'est pas très clair mais bon
certains de vos amis comme bertrand
delanoë qui dit ça manque de lisibilité
ou dit il afin de fixer le cap mais
visibilité il l'a donnée lors de sa
conférence de presse
et il la redonne dans des déplacements
il fera d'autres déplacements et
s'exprimera au fond le président la
république doit donner le sens de
l'action qui est menée et demandé au
gouvernement de s'inscrire dans ce sens
là moi je crois que vous savez les
la demande de politique sociale de
politiques de pouvoir d'achat de
politiques de protection
elles doivent évidemment être portée
mais il nous faut les moyens de les
porter donc il faut redresser le pays
mais le redressement du pays c'est bien
pour de la solidarité de la protection
du pouvoir d'achat de la justice donc
nous sommes face à une période très
difficile
l'année 2013 sera sans doute une année
difficile mais tout ce que nous faisons
c'est pour permettre aux français de
vivre au mieux vous reprenez l'image de
votre père qu'elle traumatique pour dire
la situation de notre pays on risque la
sortie de route l'accident social en
france vers un arbre tout à l'heure nous
évoquions à les économies à réaliser au
cours des prochaines années
elles sont gigantesques vous l'avez
souligné vous même puisque on sera on a
besoin de trouver 60 milliards
d'économies en plus des efforts fiscaux
qui ont été demandés aux français
pendant la période
donc on voit bien qu'on est à un moment
où c'est la réévaluation de nos
politiques mais la réévaluation de nos
politiques
elle n'a de sens que si elle permet aux
français encore une fois de vivre mieux
moi je suis en charge d'une partie des
politiques sociales
ce sont des politiques de protection et
cela qui est au coeur du modèle social
français doit être préservée même si la
manière dont on protège doit pouvoir
évoluer derrière quelqu'un aurait-il
proche des idées de dominique strauss
kahn devait rejoindre le c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui quand vous avez entendu
pendant la campagne mon ennemi c'est la
finance dsk n'aurait jamais prononcé une
phrase comme ça ce que vous avez senti
un peu forcément sur la même longueur
d'onde non je je je crois à la cohérence
des choix que j'ai fait françois
hollande a porté d'emblée une ligne
réformiste social démocrate dans
laquelle je me retrouve pleinement et je
me suis retrouvé pleinement au moment où
j'ai fait le choix de le soutenir vous
êtes une ministre heureuse donc à
l'écouté je crois pas que la question du
bonheur soit la question mais
franchement
non franchement j'ai de très grosses ou
lourde responsabilité j'en suis fier
vous en êtes fier merci et votre père
aussi ont la vie il ya un instant
merci michael szames s merci marisol
touraine nous nous retrouverons le 8
janvier maintenant avec luc chatel et
qui va jouer un rôle prépondérant au
sein de l'ump pacifié enfin lui toujours
côté copé bonsoir être habité bonnes
feuilles
le vrai courage gilles leclair s'est pas
d'augmenter les impôts tout le monde
sait le faire nicolas sarkozy est parti
mais la crise est pas partir la
politique économique du gouvernement
je lui donnerai un zéro pointé tous les
matins à 8 heures 15
guillaume durand et gilles leclair
reçoivent une personnalité politique
dans l'invité politique reconstruire sa
crédibilité
reconstruire sa popularité il faut pas
préjuger on peut juger après en
partenariat avec radio classique
l'invité politique
tous les matins à 8h 15 en direct sur
public sénat
bonjour à tous bienvenue à banne ce
merveilleux village reculé sur tous
perchés quelque part dans le sud de
l'ardèche ici une bataille a marqué le
pays à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale une embuscade hardiment menées
par les partisans les résistants c'était
à quelques kilomètres d'ici
dans la vallée une bataille d'envergure
qui a stoppé net la progression d'une
importante colonne allemande en route
vers le nord du pays un homme occupe une
place très singulière dans cet épisode
de l'histoire cet homme c'est paul maës
il était maire du village
en ce mois de juillet 1944 et depuis
très peu de temps depuis moins d'un an
la toute nouvelle école de ban porte
désormais son nom
voilà je me trouve maintenant dans cette
magnifique salle de classe de la toute
nouvelle école de bane un an et demi à
peine j'ai rejoins l'un des professeurs
de l'école frédéric le clech bonjour
bonjour avec devant vous et bien vos
élèves vos enfants une classe de cm2 cm1
bonjour à tous alors fédérer que le
clash cette école s'appelle paul maes
est ce que c'est un nom que vous
connaissiez il ya encore quelques mois
je les ai découverts quand ils ont nommé
cette école et auparavant n'étant pas
moi-même debanne auparavant je ne
connaissais pas du tout ce personnage
vous avez peut-être regarder les plaques
qui sont sur l'école elle-même parce que
vous êtes intéressé à ce personnage
demain à partir de ce moment là j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser à me demander
d'abord qu'est-ce qu'il avait bien pu
faire et puis d'où venait ce nom ce qui
n'est pas un patronyme d'origine
ardéchoise française et donc j'ai fait
quelques recherches
alors votre école les enfants elle
s'appelle paul maes est ce que ce nom
vous le connaissez est ce que ça vous
dit quelque chose
bah j'ai pas connue mais c'était le
maire de vannes 2-2 ce que ce que j'ai
écouté ce que j'ai entendu quand ici
alors paul maïs il était maire de bad
mais quand quand il la bataille de ban
et c'était quand
en 1804 quarante quatre pôles match
était maire en 1944 c'est à dire pendant
la guerre pendant la guerre oui la
seconde guerre mondiale et la shoah vais
le village il était mary là ils lâchent
au vél a été réaliste en est là il a
combattu également et c'est bien ce
qu'il a fait paul maes je trouve ça non
eric vrai que le clash merci beaucoup
nous avoir accueillis chez vous dans
votre salle de classe sinon qu'il vous
remerciant à très bientôt on va essayer
maintenant d'en savoir un peu plus sur
paul maes et sur cette fameuse bataille
de bam merci les enfants à très bientôt
au revoir
alors vous l'avez compris en cette fin
du mois de juillet 1944 paul maes le
maire de ban n'est pas tout à fait un
personnage comme les autres son action
elle intervient quelques jours à peine
après ce qu'on appelle ici la bataille
de ban autrement dit la plus grande
bataille de la résistance ici dans le
département de l'ardèche
je rejoint raul gala tout il est
historien c'est l'un des meilleurs
spécialistes de cette résistance
ardéchoise
bonjour raul galatto est-ce que yoann
aujourd'hui ensemble au village tel
qu'il existait en juillet 1944 pour
l'échangé louit avec son aspect
pittoresque que jugée sur sa colline de
rochers calcaires les chais ruines du
vieux château bon il ya des quelques
maisons nouvelles mais pour l'essentiel
oui c'est très typique
ban a joué un rôle tout à fait
particulier dans cette résistance
ardéchoise
eh oui bam se trouve situé en bordure
d'une route à l'époque aux routes
nationales qui avait une importance
stratégique pour les armées allemandes
d'occupation dans tout le sud de la
france y compris le languedoc et les
volontaires des forces françaises de
l'intérieur c'est-à-dire les forces
armées de la résultante ont été amenés à
livrer quelques escarmouches contrôler
ces convois allemands qui circulait qui
étaient ces résistants qui ont participé
à la bataille de bain des jeunes
volontaires paysans et autres de la
région de bâle ont rejoints par des
maquisards et épais venus du gard
principalement des ouvriers mineurs dans
des semaines il ya eu évidemment parmi
les réfugiés qui ont rejoint la
résistance plusieurs l'ancien
républicains espagnols qu'on a retrouvés
dans cette compagnie aussi donc c'était
très diversifié bon au départ il y avait
quelques centaines de volontaires le 6
juin
fin juillet devait y avoir cinq ou six
mille volontaires dans le département de
l'ardèche qui était organisé en compagne
et donc encadré convenablement on avait
trouvé quand même quelques militaires
des anciens qui avait fait la guerre
14-18 tous acquis près qu'ils avaient
quelques compétences c'est ce qui leur a
permis de livrer un combat qui
finalement était le premier combat
victorieux à ain ardèche qui a précédé
de quelques jours la libération de
privas la première préfecture de france
libérée par la résistance le 12 août
avant même le débarquement des troupes
alliées jeu là